but can you see a set of facts where
the end result is you know what we're
good with washington football team we're
good with this look we're going to ride
it out for a few more years yeah i mean
all things all things are on the table
and i think that's perfectly fair that's
actually you know again to your point a
much more narrow hypothesis and fair
like it could absolutely go that path
but i think uh along that way we're
going to be engaging fans substantively
we're going to be engaging players
substantively sponsors the staff
and and frankly and i don't have it
quite in my head yet i know our
marketing team has thought through this
much more than me giving up you know day
negative four whatever it is um but
engaging the dmv the leaders and
influencers in the dmv community more
broadly are going to have input on that
as well but yeah that could absolutely
be the pace i mean you know it's a
little bit into into me that people will
find out a lot and you'll follow you if
you if you actually scroll my twitter
you'll see that i'm quite the european
football fan
um in the background
that's that's a perfectly fine name
right in that in that world it's a
perfectly fine name in that world so
it's not anathema to me but it's not
going to be my decision by any means
it's going to be a community-based
decision and we'll see where we land
[Music]
anytime i hear dmv i think department of
motor vehicles he's talking about dc
maryland virginia area they really are
keeping the community involved i was
wondering on their twitter page
different names getting thrown out there
look have some fun with it exhaust all
possibilities turn over every rock and
then eventually make the right decision
but if the team is successful
with the current name
which isn't a name and the current
uniforms which are indeed awesome why
change it people will fall in love with
it you could whatever the name is if the
team is successful people will like it
and this isn't it's just for it's just
so amazing to me chris they were as low
as they could have been with all the
stuff that's gone on and it just
it's like it just turned it did and it
feels like everything they're doing now
is
is the exact opposite of everything
they've done for 20 years and it all
feels like it's working and it's falling
together and i hope it continues because
those fans deserve it after 21 years of
dysfunction they deserve the opposite of
dysfunction yeah no they do and there's
been some positive stories i mean we
like the uniforms we've liked the
helmets lately yeah you hire jason
wright you know the first black man to
be a team president those things i mean
that's positive stuff so yeah when you
call and then alex smith that success
story so it has been a little bit of a
positive thing around washington right
now i'm with you mike i like the
washington football team i mean i think
it's kind of cool and you know and a
success or not success i hope people can
get behind it he made a good example
about european football i mean it's not
that crazy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports